Most people in Silicon Valley, you know,
they have a hammer
and everything is a nail.
And that hammer is tools
and they're going to build
a tool for everything.
And the mindset is pure software,
AI is going to do everything,
humans are irrelevant.
Humans aren't even
going to exist in the future.
Francis Pedraza,
thank you so much for joining me
on 20 Minute Leaders.
Thanks for having me, Michael.
It's a pleasure to have you.
We actually met
for the first time seven years ago.
You came to speak to our summer class
at MIT LaunchX.
It was about Everest, which I know
that it's a long time back for you now
with all the different things
that you've done since then.
But thank you for being
such a source of inspiration
for us back then.
It was really fantastic.
Thanks for remembering
and for reaching out.
Of course. Of course.
I'm really excited to have you here.
Francis, I'm not going to do justice
to go over the incredible bio,
because you've actually had
a pretty incredible upbringing.
A pretty global one.
But all sorts of diverse activities.
I would love to just spend
the first few minutes going
a little bit over your journey.
Who are you?
What are your passions?
And I think that will be
a really good leeway into
the things you're doing today,
and some source of inspiration
for young entrepreneurs like myself.
My mother grew up in Iran
and came to United States
before the revolution.
But when the revolution happened,
her world changed.
And she had finished her undergrad
but she dropped out of graduate school,
became an entrepreneur
and worked really, really hard
to succeed and did.
And then when she had me,
she sold her company
and focused on raising me.
My father grew up around the world.
His father worked for Procter and Gamble
and other American companies.
So, he spent some time
growing up in places like Japan
and the Philippines and Venezuela.
And so, you know, I think
I got the immigrant value set,
which is a lot of hustle
and determination and hard work
and a sense of, I think, patriotism
for the United States.
This is a place where dreams can happen
and you're in a free country,
you have property rights, rule of law,
and you can build something here
and express your potential.
And that was my upbringing.
And my life changed,
I was pretty frustrated
in both public and private schools
for a variety of reasons
until I discovered
this incredible Internet entrepreneur
who is teaching
hundreds of students on Skype.
Zoom did not exist back then.
But he happened to be a local.
And he was teaching them
a five year course
in the great books
of Western Civilization.
And the first book we studied
was Homer's Iliad,
and then the next was The Odyssey.
And then we went on
to read many of the ancient Greeks
and the Romans and then
the medieval Scholastics, Renaissance
and Enlightenment and Moderns
and a number of subjects.
And reading the original sources,
writing about them,
debating them, discussing them.
And so, I developed this passion
for the humanities.
And people asked me,
"How did you go from that
to starting a company?"
And my first company was called Everest.
You remember it.
It was an iPhone app
to help people achieve personal goals.
And I thought that Steve Jobs
had this metaphor that technology
could be a bicycle
for the human mind, you know,
that it would almost be
like an Iron Man suit.
Like we could express our potential
with these tools
at a pace that
we'd never been able to before.
You could move
on the speed of thought.
And then, we sort of live
in this dystopian reality where,
you know that t shirt
that has, like, you know,
the ape and then
a homo sapiens standing tall
and then humans behind a laptop
and then we look like an ape again.
It's like we live
in this dystopian reality
where it feels like we're slaves
to our devices instead of
the other way around
where these technologies
are empowering us.
Like, why is that.
And so, with Everest,
I was trying to build a social network
except around doing things
instead of around who you know.
And you would have
all your goals in the app.
And I thought that
we could live up
to that Da Vinci and Dream,
have a new renaissance
and have people pursue
their full potential
and have technology actually help.
But the company failed.
The app failed.
And it was a very humbling
sort of Icarus experience where
I had to learn a number of lessons,
both about how to build a great product,
how to build a great business.
But it also made me rethink
some of the fundamentals.
And with Invisible, my current company,
I've tried not to compromise
on the vision.
I think same vision.
Just different business model,
different mission.
And I've been trying
to apply the learnings
to solve a very, very different problem,
which is industrializing knowledge work.
So, before we go into that,
I have to go back a little bit
and understand about
that Icarus-like experience.
Because inevitably, you know,
almost all entrepreneurs
are going to fail multiple times
until they get to their success.
And I'd love to focus
a little bit on this side of the story.
I remember when you came
to speak to us,
I remember how we all looked
at this amazing product
that you are building,
and the charisma and the vision.
And we all bought into it immediately.
We knew this was going to be
a major success.
We loved it.
And you have to understand, Francis,
that this is a bunch of you know,
16, 17 year-olds entrepreneur wannabes,
that they're getting so excited
and are buying into these products.
I need to have this closure
to understand what happened there
and why do you call this
an Icarus-like experience?
And what lessons really
do you translate now
to your next venture?
Yeah.
It was a beautiful product.
Apple featured it many times,
I think the design community recognized
the work that our designers had done.
And it was before Facebook
had an iPhone app.
Remember when they were
Facebook thought their corporate strategy
for a few years
was they were going to be Web only.
Until they realized
that it was a mistake.
It was the early days of the App Store.
And we had nearly half
a million people use it.
And their initial experience
with Everest was kind of this,
you know, euphoric experience.
Wow, I could put all my goals
and dreams into the app.
I want to go to Italy.
I want to look like Daniel Craig
in a bathing suit.
I want to run a marathon.
I want to buy a house.
You know, all the things,
you just fantasize, almost,
that part was easy.
But where the business failed
is that three, four, five,
six months later,
people would stop making progress
on their goals.
It was almost like Instagram
for your goals
where you could post photos and videos,
but also complete steps
like a checklist and make progress.
And the discipline required was too high.
So, our business model
ended up looking like a gym.
You know, gyms don't make money
when you get fit.
Gyms make money
when you want to get fit.
They divorce monetization from retention.
And that was a key principle
that we'd missed.
And we thought
we were going to be
a business model look like Facebook.
But basically that business model
is selling dopamine like a drug
and like a digital cigarette.
And it doesn't really require effort
or follow through.
And so, oops, a beginner's mistake.
And that was the Icarus moment.
So, fast forward to today.
Tell me a little bit about
the insights of the industry
in the market even before
we get to the actual product.
Because you have
some really fascinating insights
into where we're headed
as a global economy, and the workforce,
and that's leading into what
you are working on today.
So, I'd love to really
get into your mind,
and understand the motivation
behind what you are you doing
and taking a little bit
of a leap forward into
what's going to happen
in the next few decades.
Yeah. I'll start by describing
what Invisible is
and then I'll share some,
some predictions about the future.
So, every company has complex
and custom processes
and they're very difficult to automate.
Even if you know about
all the latest automation tools,
even if you're aware
of robotic process automation, RPA tools
or workflow
or no code automation tools,
or you're aware of the relevant,
you know, software point solutions
for the particular function
you're trying to automate.
So, it's sales or hiring, the marketing
or an industry specific, you know,
workflow you're trying to build.
They're all these tools.
There's an app for everything,
why isn't everything perfect yet.
And the answer is that when you try
to automate your process,
any one tool might help you automate
five, 10, 15% of it.
But you can't get
the end to end solution you need
to run your business tomorrow.
So, what do you do?
You either do the rest of it
in-house manually,
or you outsource it
to a traditional outsourcing company.
A business process outsource or a BPO.
And BPOs are like law firms.
Their incentive is to bill you
as many hours as possible.
They're selling labor
They don't have an incentive
to automate on their side.
So, Invisible is combining outsourcing
and automation for the first time,
and we call it work sharing.
And our technology
is a digital assembly line.
And it has two layers:
the first is we coordinate 280 workers
in 35 countries around the world
who can log in to secure virtual desktops
and follow step by step instructions
to do the manual portions of the work;
and then the second layer
is that we break down
these custom processes
into standard steps.
We think of it like sequencing
in the corporate process genome,
and then we will automate
those steps over time
and they become reusable.
And our business model is a win win.
As we automate your process,
your unit price goes down
and our margins go up.
So, it's a win win.
We have an incentive to automate
and you see your prices drop.
And our inspiration for all this
was what Henry Ford did
to manufacturing
in the early 20th century.
Every, you know,
this is like pre world war I.
I mean, the whole story
of Ford from like 1908
to say, 1960, is fascinating.
But every year,
the quality of their cars improved,
the price decreased,
their revenue increased,
their margins increased,
and the amount that they paid
their workers increased.
These things are
in trade off relationships.
This shouldn't happen.
And it only happens through
the economic miracle
of productivity gains
which create deflation.
And deflation is good.
I call it
the deflationary gospel of capitalism.
Better, faster, cheaper,
better, faster, cheaper.
And I think that
we're at a stage where
the mission of the company, with Invisible,
is industrializing knowledge work.
It's not automating knowledge work.
It's industrializing it.
And it implies
a more nuanced view of automation.
And this is what I'd like
to communicate to your audience.
Most people in Silicon Valley,
they have a hammer
and everything is a nail.
And that hammer is tools.
And they're going to build
a tool for everything.
And the mindset is pure software.
AI is going to do everything.
Humans are irrelevant.
Humans aren't even going
to exist in the future.
Ultron is coming.
And I think this is ridiculous.
And I think this is where some
of the liberal arts background kicks in.
I think, in many times
in our history,
we've always thought
we're at an exponential curve
and it didn't end up happening.
Things happened quite differently.
If you read Steinbeck's Grapes of Wrath,
for example, with the tractors coming
and automating agriculture,
arguably the productivity gains
of that era were greater than the ones
that we're experiencing today.
This is what I think is likely to happen.
I'll speak in
very broad statistical terms.
There are just,
a pop quiz for your audience.
There are eight billion people
on the planet,
how many people play video games?
Think about it. Put the answer in your head.
Two billion.
It's three billion.
Three to four billion.
And then how many people
do knowledge work?
Like, make their livelihood
on a computer in some way?
One billion.
You did your homework.
Exactly.
So, there are one third to one quarter
as many knowledge workers
as there are video gamers.
Now, I'm going to attribute this
to Cathie Wood at ARK Invest,
whose research I follow closely.
But basically video gaming
is like a sort of onboarding.
It's training for the world's
future knowledge workers.
And if you think about
what's going to happen over
the course of our lifetime,
do we think
there are going to be less than
a billion knowledge workers
by the time we die
or more than a billion knowledge workers.
And it just seems sort of obvious,
sort of ask the audience
to grant it to me
as a premise or an axiom
or an assumption.
I could defend it, but I just think
it's so sort of obvious
on its face that
there are going to be many, many
more knowledge workers.
It doesn't make sense
that one out of every eight people,
work on the Internet.
And seven out of every eight people work
in the physical world.
The digital world
is becoming more and more part
of everything that we do.
Every industry
is basically becoming digitized.
So. I think they're complimentary trends
in robotics, you know.
But I think that basically
in our lifetime, we're going to have
up to four billion knowledge workers,
maybe more.
So, think about what that means
in terms of automation.
If we were actually going
to automate even 50%
of knowledge work,
then we would go
from a billion knowledge workers
to 500 million knowledge workers
in our lifetime.
And 500 million other people
would have to either be unemployed
or find some physical work to do.
But I think the opposite
is going to occur.
I think what we're going to experience
is net negative automation.
That doesn't mean
we're not going to automate.
We're going to automate a lot.
But I think the key economic principle
is work can be created faster
than it can be destroyed.
And we can destroy it pretty fast.
We can industrialize it and automate it
and build all these tools pretty fast.
But not as quickly as we can create it.
And I think that we're going to be
in a sort of dialectic
where humans are doing a thing
and then computers learn
how to do that thing.
And then humans do another thing,
like a new trick
that we then teach
the robots and then
we're going to keep doing that dialectic
for a lot longer than people think.
And I think that you want to design
your business model around that,
or at least our business model
has been designed around that.
I think that those are going to be
the really interesting opportunities.
Not necessarily the selling pure,
pure SaaS, pure tools.
Francis, why do you care
so much about this? Why?
I mean, I saw how much you cared
about Everest.
I saw that passion.
And I'm seeing the passion now.
I'm feeling as if I'm back
in that MIT class in 2013.
Why do you care so much
about this stuff?
Because the future doesn't,
I mean, almost by definition,
should be very different than the past
and presumably better.
And I think one way
of thinking about it is
if you saw a human being
that was seven feet tall,
you'd be like,
wow, that person is pretty tall.
You saw a human being
that was eight feet tall.
You'd be like, are you
in the Guinness Book of World Records?
Like, you're like
three standard deviations, tall.
If you saw a human being
that was 70 feet tall,
you'd call the military.
It's an alien.
It's not a human anymore.
It's like, you know, it's Godzilla.
It's a giant.
There are just not
80 foot tall humans.
But that's a metaphor
for what is possible
with productivity gains.
And I think that
the mindset of Silicon Valley
has been the Turing test,
which is when can computers do
all the things that humans can do
that we can't tell.
And I think that that's the wrong test
for a number of reasons.
I think the more interesting test
is the da Vinci test, which is I think
Steve Jobs's original intent.
Which is, you know,
in the 21st century,
when will the average person
be more productive
than the most productive person
in the 15th century.
And I think that in sort of a
a one on one productivity test,
da Vinci with his piece of paper,
would school any millennial
with their laptop and iPhone.
And I think that
that's the embarrassing thing.
That we have all this information
and all these tools,
and yet we're spending
so much of our time
not being creative
and not being strategic.
So, I think part of my message is,
is deeply optimistic.
I think I really believe in the good
that humans are capable of.
But part of it is like a real
reprimand in a sense,
like an exhortation.
Like we,
Harvard said that up to 50%,
41% of the average knowledge workers time
is spent doing work that is repetitive.
And I think we just did not
get the education
and the opportunities that we have.
And we do not live
in this incredible era
in order to spend half
of our time doing irrelevant,
doing work that
isn't our highest contribution.
Right?
And we should have a certain urgency
around solving problems, creating things.
And I think that,
Peter Thiel has I think,
has the right philosophy,
the right pessimism
in his basic message,
which is that like, you know,
the iPhone is new,
our digital devices are new,
but when you walk around our cities,
they still feel like
they're in the 20th century.
Why is that.
You know.
And I think that there are,
Cathie Wood in ARK Invest
talks about five technology platforms
that are disrupting
pretty much have the potential
to disrupt every aspect of our society.
I think the five are,
I'm going to hope I get this right:
FinTech and blockchain
robotics and industrial automation,
AI and automation,
which Invisible is in,
and sort of software automation
enterprise tools,
the genomic revolution,
everything is happening
with CRISPR and gene editing
and everything that's happening
with autonomous vehicles.
I think those are the five.
But the reason I list them out
is that there's, you know,
this is such an exciting time
to be alive.
But we kind of have
to have a fire about it.
What's the phrase,
"light a fire under your ass".
I can definitely feel the fire,
the passion, the urgency.
I'm getting so much inspiration.
But Francis, before we end,
you have to tell me
the Peter Thiel story.
You told it to me seven years ago
back in MIT launch with Everest.
I need the short version now
for the audience.
Because it will be just fascinating.
If you feel comfortable with it,
of course.
Sure.
So, yeah.
He is one of the people
that I look up to most.
Still to this day,
I think he's an intellectual giant.
And I just graduated from college
and I was starting Everest
and I had some people interested
in investing but hadn't been able
to make a breakthrough there.
And I met someone at an airport.
You know,
right when pretty much
I was thinking about quitting
and I was working
on the designs for the app.
And somebody
looked over my shoulder
and saw the designs.
And then asked me some questions
and I answered them
and I told them about
the idea and he said,
"Would you like to raise money?"
And I said, "Yes."
And they said, "For who?"
Well, you know, from who
angels or VCs.
And I said,
"Angels. But specifically,
Peter Thiel."
He's like,
"Well, I actually happened
to go to Stanford with Peter
and I can introduce you."
And I spent half an hour,
tops, talking to Peter,
telling him about it.
And he said,
"Well, send me some some materials."
And I just wrote
a 50 page business plan.
Everest created one of the first
web based pitch decks.
And we released it right around Christmas
and didn't hear from him.
And then New Year's Eve,
sure, I'm in for 50k.
And then everyone else came in
and we raised two point six million
and did this journey
for three or four years.
And it was a lucky break.
But something I think
I'm always going to be grateful for
and I think they're still,
I think it's a good example of some magic,
you know.
There are certain things
like generally, you should operate
with assumption that every single win
you have to fully earn it.
And, you know,
but as I look back over my career,
there have been
a number of people that have
given me favor and key moments,
and those were fortunate circumstances,
I'm very grateful for them.
And I think that's part
of what made Silicon Valley great.
And I think it's still there.
Francis, I love it.
Thank you for sharing the story.
Thank you for sharing
all the other stories.
This was just inspiring
to listen to again
and with the new insights.
And I can't wait
to keep following your journey
and continue getting inspired.
So, thank you for everything
that you're doing.
Both to me, the listeners,
but also to humanity,
when with all the different products
that your building.
Before we leave, I have to ask you
the most important question,
which is three words that you
would use to describe yourself.
And I know that
I'm already keeping you late,
so thank you for being
generous with your time.
Yeah.
Iconoclast, classicist and amateur.
Iconoclast, because I tend
to go against the norms,
even when the norms are aesthetic.
Contrarian is a word we're familiar with.
But iconoclasm has a sort
of aesthetic connotation
that sometimes,
being a contrarian kind of,
it's actually unpopular and weird
and even can look ugly.
And it's like, what are you doing,
it's a weirdo.
And I think you have to embrace that.
And then classicists, because I think
that which is ancient,
is often futuristic.
There's the things that don't change
that you can learn the most from.
And I think reading original sources
in general is good,
and particularly when it comes to books.
I love reading books by dead people.
Then amateur, because
in the old word "amatore",
you have to have a certain love
for trying new things
and being like a child
and making mistakes.
So, I have many things
that I do that I'm not an expert in
by any stretch of the imagination.
Like I love to paint.
I love to learn about subjects
I know very little about.
Like I was reading a bunch
of white papers about
autonomous vehicles
and it's totally out of my depth.
But, hey, I think
that helps make you well-rounded.
And I think that
for a couple hundred years,
everyone's been trying
to become more specialized.
But I think going back
to the Renaissance idea
of being the polymath and being versatile
is a better way to go.
But to do that, you have to embrace
the identity of an amateur.
Francis, thank you so, so much.
This is wonderful.
Stay safe and stay healthy.
Thank you again.
Cheers Michael.